[MUSIC PLAYING]
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
I will give you
a quick overview about the
Recommended for G Suite
Program, what's the background,
why did we start it at Google,
and also what are the
key benefits for you
the customers of this program?
And then we'll turn this into
a very dynamic session where
we have a fireside chat with
six of all recommended ISVs
and our joint customers,
who will tell you
a phenomenal story of how
they implemented some our ISV
solutions together with
their G Suite deployment,
and made it very useful for
their colleagues and employees
in the organization.
And then we'll turn it
to you and open it up
for an audience Q&A with
of our 12 fireside chat
panelists on stage.
So it's going to be a
very exciting session.
Since you've all been here
throughout the entire week
and attended lots of keynotes,
lots of the breakout sessions,
I don't think I have to spend
too much time on this topic.
And probably you all agree with
us hearing around all the news,
the customer
testimonials that we had,
and Diane and Tarrick's keynote.
But also yesterday,
and especially
during Brian Stephens and
[? Probaka's ?] announcements
around all the new products
that we launched this week
that Google is a pioneer
with regards to the shift
to the cloud.
And lots of your customers
that are in the same boat
think exactly the same way.
With regards to G Suite,
if you remember the number
that [? Probaka ?]
announced yesterday,
three million businesses--
and all of those
are paying businesses-- have
gone and have become G Suite
customers.
And when you see those
[INAUDIBLE] slides,
usually we put on the big
global multinational customers,
the big logos that
everybody recognizes.
But in fact, at
Google we also care
about the small and
medium sized businesses
and the mid-market businesses.
And all of them have
something in common.
Whenever they became
a G Suite customer,
one thing that they enabled
is they made their employees
or colleagues more productive,
more collaborative, more
effective, and more
efficient in their all day
professional life.
And that is great.
But we also recognize
that's only a start.
Because with G Suite,
Google is not that arrogant.
We can only solve so and
so many business problems
And your company more productive
with regards to collaboration.
However, businesses
are much more complex,
and enterprise processes
that need to be solved
require also
different solutions.
And there are lots and lots of
different technology software
partners out there
that actually provide
exactly the right solutions
for those problems,
and they integrate
very well with G Suite.
So that's why we at Google
and our global technology
partnership team believes
in a very strong third party
ecosystem which we call ISVs,
independent software vendors.
And we started to work with
them very deliberately.
However, the feedback that
we got from lots of customers
like you is, it's very
difficult to navigate
a system, and the entire
ecosystem of third party
solution vendors and ISVs.
These Because you want to make
the transition to the cloud,
and Google wants
to be your guide
and your help in that
transition to the cloud.
However, its very difficult
to actually navigate it
in terms of how to discover the
best third party solution apps.
If you look at the
G Suite marketplace,
and I assume most of you
have visited already,
there are actually more than
1,000 different ISV vendors
in the G Suite
marketplace listed.
So its very difficult to
find the right ones for you.
And we understand that you
might have the capabilities,
but you might not have the
time to actually navigate
this entire forest
of ISV solutions.
Then second of all, if you're
the IT admin or decision maker,
you want to know actually
whether those solutions that
are listed somewhere and
that you find somewhere
in the marketplace, whether
they actually work well
with your existing productivity
suite, so Google and G Suite.
And then I think it was
a very common thread
throughout the entire week.
I think there was
no breakout session
that I attended where security
didn't come up as a topic.
So very relevant, a hot
topic probably for all of us
here in the room.
The topic around security.
You want to know
when you buy one
of those solutions, a third
party solution that might not
have a big brand name yet,
are those solutions actually
secure?
And then last of
all is we've seen it
for the entire week
the announcement.
Google is very innovative,
moves very fast.
So you want to have some
security around the roadmap.
There needs to be
some alignment,
does Google actually stand
behind those solutions?
Lots of challenges.
But at Google, the good thing
is we love to solve problems.
And that's why we've created
this solution, which we believe
is a very proper
solution to your problems
and the challenges
that we've heard.
We've created this program, it's
called Recommended for G Suite,
and we announced it
in November 2015.
What it means is,
it's the first time
ever that Google has
started to publicly endorse
a subset of technology vendors,
third party solutions, ISVs,
that integrate very
well with our solution.
You can find more about
it on our website,
and a short link is
g.co/appsrecommended.
The critical part,
and this is where
I want to spend some time,
is what does it actually
mean for you as the customer?
So what did we try to
achieve with this program?
Number one, all of the
ISVs in his program
has been vetted on
a security standard
so that they all meet and
fulfill Google security
and compliance standards.
And as you've heard
probably yesterday,
I think, in the
[INAUDIBLE] keynote,
it was a very common thread.
It's a very high bar that
you have to jump there.
Let me tell you a bit
about the process, twofold.
First vetting process
is internally.
Google security operations teams
and also our security engineers
vet all of the solutions
that we believe
should be in this program.
If they master that
step, the second step
is that we at Google,
we don't trust ourselves
enough for that even.
We want to make sure that the
third party, a neutral party--
and we hire an external
security consultant for that--
is actually vetting
those solutions as well.
So they do some
additional [INAUDIBLE]
testing around a solution.
And then when they
get that stamp
they will be qualified
from the security angle.
Second element, all of the ISVs
that are in this Recommended
for G Suite program,
they fulfill
our standards
around integrations
and also employment practices.
So there's a second hurdle that
you have to overcome in order
to be part of this program.
The third part is
one of the challenges
that I mentioned before.
It's around the roadmap.
If you watched the
[? Probakas ?] keynote
yesterday, you probably
saw some of the logos
that you will see
on the next slide.
Lots of the ISVs that we
have in this program work
very closely with our
product management
teams and engineering teams
whenever we have new product
launches so that the
integrations don't break,
and we're very
tightly integrated
and try to facilitate new,
very exciting integrations
at the time of the launch of
new Google products, as well.
The fourth element
of the program
is around discoverability.
And it should be very easy for
you to find those solutions
if we pre-vetted
them, et cetera.
So if you had a G Suite
admin on your domain,
you will find them.
There is a very popular
section in the G Suite admin
panel where those ISV
solutions are highlighted.
But also you have
events like these
where we bring in some of
those ISVs or joint customers
to tell you more
about the solutions,
and the great deployments
and experiences
that our customers have.
But also our sales teams and
strategic account managers
are actually briefed
on those solutions.
So you will always have
persons that are very well
aware of those solutions.
And then the last point is from
the inception of this program,
we knew we needed to create
a thriving ecosystem.
And the ecosystem means
customers, it means Google,
it means those ISV partners.
But also our reseller
partners, who
are part of our
entire ecosystem,
and how we go to
market at Google.
So we have encouraged
from the get-go
our reseller partners as eyes
and distribution partners
to actually work with
us together and actually
facilitate those relationships
with the recommended ISVs,
as well.
And they've built up lots
of those capabilities
throughout the process.
And that's on a global scale.
We have those resellers
in all the regions,
and I see some of the faces
in the room, actually.
Now coming specifically to the
program, who is in the program?
We've expended the program.
There's a wave two
already, and we currently
have 10 different
categories that we
cover with 15 different
ISVs in the entire program.
And if you wonder
what actually made
us decide on those
categories, those
were the categories where we
saw highest initial demand
from our enterprise customers,
and from our SMB customers
in some of the categories.
So we decided to go
with those categories,
and then found the right
vendors in those categories.
Since we will have six of them
on stage with me later today
for the fireside chat, I'll just
focus on the categories that
are not with us here on stage.
In the customer
support category,
we will have Freshdesk
as our recommended ISV.
In the CRM category,
ProsperWorks, and both of them
have a booth downstairs
if you want to visit them.
In the transaction management
e-signature category,
we have DocuSign as
our recommended ISV.
In finance and accounting, more
on the accounting side, Zero
and [INAUDIBLE] Invoice
as our recommended ISVs.
Identity and access
management, Octa and Ping.
And you can visit Octa
downstairs, as well,
at their booth.
And then in project and
process management, Asana
and Smartsheet.
And maybe a special
call out to Smartsheet.
It's one of the ISVs that
has done a phenomenal job
on the integration
side, and seamlessly
integrate with 16 different
touch points across the G Suite
ecosystem, and our
different apps.
Now we're switching gears
into the more dynamic part,
and probably the more exciting
part of the entire session.
So I would like to welcome
Powertools and their customer,
and Dialpad on stage
for the fireside chat.
So the audience, let me first
introduce Marshall Wilson.
Marshall is the senior director
of alliances and channel
management at Powertools,
and Powertools
is one of our recommended ISVs
in the document management
system category.
And what that means
is Drive is excellent,
and probably most of you have
been very looking forward
to the team Drive
announcement yesterday.
But there's even more
they can do with Drive,
and you can turn it to a
real document management
system with our
very integrated ISVs
that we have in this category.
Marshall, why don't you
introduce your customer?
Who did you bring
with you today?
MARSHALL WILSON: Thanks,
Thorsten, first and foremost.
And welcome everyone,
thanks for being here.
So here today we are with one of
our valued customers, Droga 5.
And specifically,
Jennifer, the head of IT.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Jennifer?
JENNIFER CANDELARIO: Yes?
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Do
you want to quickly tell
the audience what Droga 5 is?
Because I don't think
everybody knows the company.
JENNIFER CANDELARIO: All right.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Jennifer Candelario
from Droga 5.
Droga 5 is an advertising
agency based in New York.
You may know some of
our most recent work.
We did the campaign for
the Google Pixel phone
that recently just
launched last year.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
And then why don't
we continue with you?
What was the baseline
back in the days when
you decided to actually explore
a new document management
system bender?
JENNIFER CANDELARIO: We were
in the process of implementing
a digital asset management
system for our production
department, and that was going
to be an in-house solution.
We were looking for
some kind of solution
that we could use
with Google Drive.
We had over four million
assets, and it was almost
like a black hole.
So we looked to Powertools to
help us manage that solution.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Is that a very common
situation that you see,
Marshall, or the different
baselines that you usually
see whenever you have
prospect reaching out
to you and Powertools?
MARSHALL WILSON: Yeah,
that's one of two usually.
We see two specific
kind of baselines
like you're talking about.
The first one is companies that
are investing in the G Suite,
but maybe aren't leveraging
Drive to its full capacity,
and still are having some
kind of external document
repository that they want
to bring on to Drive.
And to do that, if they have
a large amount of documents,
they're going to need
help with a solution
like ours to be able to keep
track, organize, and track
these documents, right?
The second one is Drive
users, current companies
who have leveraged drive but
want to go a step further.
Not just using it for
storage and collaboration,
but also creating and
optimizing business processes
around workflows,
metadata, things like that.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
Excellent Jennifer,
next question for you.
What was your
selection process like,
and what were the key
parameters that you looked at,
and what made you
decide to actually go
with Powertools at the end?
JENNIFER CANDELARIO:
Well, at Droga 5
I'm fairly lucky when
it comes to vetting out
different vendors.
Executive management
has left that on my lap,
and they let me do
my own exploring
on who I want to work with.
So Powertools was one of
a few different vendors
that we looked at, and basically
what we do is a lot of demoing.
And we have one or two
teams work on it in house.
And we just do the same project
but on different platforms,
and see which one we think
the rest of the agency
would like to work with.
Once we've done that-- and trust
me, we annoy our sales rep,
because we consciously ask them
to extend our demo for another
week, another week, another
month, another two months--
we then make the selection
and decide who we want to use,
and Powertools was the
one we decided to go with.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Is that a very common decision
making process that you've
seen, Marshall, or--
MARSHALL WILSON:
Extending trials?
A little bit more than
we would like, yes,
but people take
their time, right?
Yeah, that's usually kind of
a given scenario that we see.
It was great
working with Droga 5
in the beginning, and a
lot of our other customers,
because they do
understand Google Drive,
they do like Google
Drive, but they
want to take it further, right?
So some of the key
takeaways are the fact
that using Google Drive with
Powertools, it is Google Drive,
it's in Google Drive.
And we can use it
to do things like, I
was talking about these
business processes, right?
Not even our own
documents, but maybe
like onboarding new employees,
quote proposal, contract
management, things like that.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
And I think we see a
screenshot actually
of your solution in place, and
most people that I talk to,
and customers usually
at the events,
that never see the difference
between Drive and Powertools.
MARSHALL WILSON: Yeah, it's
pretty funny, actually.
A lot of our users
don't even realize
that they're using
Powertools, they just
think it's Drive, right?
So all for the better.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Jennifer, next question for you.
What were the specific
use cases that you
helped to address with
Powertools at Droga 5,
and what was the impact
at the end of the day?
Because I know we've been
using it already for some time.
JENNIFER CANDELARIO: So
we had the opportunity
to release our global brand
guidelines to the entire agency
globally, like I said.
And we wanted to
release a document
once, we didn't
want to share it,
we kind of wanted everyone to
keep the same folder structure.
We wanted to able to
go in and make changes,
and people would be able to
go back into those folders
very easily, very non-complex.
And so we decided to launch
Powertools at that time,
and we decided that we would
write this really great email
about we were a launching
our new brand guidelines,
and that we were going
to use this new platform,
and we sent out
the instructions.
And we maybe got
three tickets back
out of 700 users who had
difficulty installing it
and get moving with it.
So it was an
exciting time for us.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: And for a
document management system,
I think that's pretty awesome.
JENNIFER CANDELARIO: Yes.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Thanks.
To wrap it up, Marshall,
what are the key
features that we haven't heard
from Powertools in this use
case that Droga 5 uses you for?
Is there anything else
that you want to add?
MARSHALL WILSON: Yeah.
So I mean the great
thing about Powertools
is that in terms of the
way that we can leverage
Drive beyond kind of just the
storage collaboration aspect,
right?
Being able to apply
metadata to documents,
launch specific workflows based
off of conditional metadata.
To do things like approve the
document, retention policies,
manage versions, convert
documents, move documents.
All of these processes can
be automated with Powertools
in a very user friendly
way, and the users
have the ability of I guess
interacting with Powertools
through an interface
that they know and love,
which is Google Drive.
So I guess the
main takeaway today
that I want to give you is
that Powertools is Drive,
everything is in
Drive, and we're
the only document management
solution that manages it
in Drive.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Thank you Jennifer,
thank you Marshall.
We'll open it up for
the audience later,
so we will see you on stage.
We are switching
categories completely.
And from document management
systems to UCAS business
communications, or unified
communications as a service,
what it stands for.
And I'm very, very
happy to actually
have Craig Walker, who is
the co-founder or founder?
CRAIG WALKER: Co-founder.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
Co-founder and CEO
of Dialpad, one
of our recommended
ISVs in the communications
space here with us today.
Welcome Craig.
CRAIG WALKER: Thanks
for having me here.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Absolutely.
And I saw you around the
floor already yesterday.
It's an exciting
conference, right?
CRAIG WALKER: Yeah, it's great.
Particularly, so,
we're former Googlers,
used to work on the
Google Voice team.
So to see how much the Google
Apps G Suite ecosystem has
grown is really impressive.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Who did you bring
with you today?
Who's your customer?
CRAIG WALKER: Yeah, I
brought Radley Meyers,
who's the VP of Sales
at Betts Recruiting
here in San Francisco.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Welcome, Radley.
RADLEY MEYERS:
Thank you very much.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Good
to have you, a local.
Could you tell us a bit about
which kind of Dialpad features
made the solution very promising
for you for Betts Recruiting
in that case, and also a
bit about how you used it,
which parts of it, and what was
the impact at Betts Recruiting?
RADLEY MEYERS: Absolutely.
So we are a recruiting team
which is heavily on the phone,
but we have six
offices globally,
and we're constantly meeting
with candidates, clients.
So our team was pretty
much strapped to their desk
if they were going
to use their phone.
So when I started
talking to Dialpad,
realizing that no matter
where our team was,
we have a young
team also, so they
like to sit at the couches
at the front, at the tables,
at the bar, at the
coffee shop downstairs.
Wherever it is.
So knowing that they could do
their job effectively, have
their calls logged, all
the integrations really
helped us to make sure that
efficiencies and productivity
was still high no matter where
they were working from home,
or whatever.
And then texting is
huge for our company.
And knowing that our team can
not use their personal phone
number to text, they
could text from the number
that a candidate or a
client already knows.
We send about 7,000
of those a week,
and I wouldn't know that if it
wasn't for Dialpad analytics.
So it's been really,
really awesome
to be able to see the
productivity from our team
continue to grow.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Craig, next question for
you as a follow up maybe.
What does Dialpad
bring to the table?
I mean, you know
Google very well,
you know G Suite
customers very well.
Why should they all be
thinking about Dialpad?
CRAIG WALKER: Yeah,
so going back,
this was a perfect example of
the anywhere worker, right?
And we saw this, again, when
we were at Google building
the Google Voice platform, is
we realized as companies move
to the cloud for their
productivity suite,
for their email,
documents, calendar, et
cetera, to then still
be tied to a desk
for their phone makes
absolutely no sense.
You've kind of empowered people
to be productive from anywhere
on any device except
for the phone.
So our whole mission was
to kill the desk phone.
In fact, we have billboards
all over that say it.
But kill the desk
phone, and really
have a super integrated product.
So you sign in with your
Google G Suite single sign on,
instantly your address
book is synced,
your company directory's synced.
And you can see on the
little screenshot there,
when I'm talking on
the phone to someone,
it'll show the last three
emails I've exchanged for them.
The last three Drive documents
we've collaborated on,
upcoming calendar appointments.
And it just makes for a really
super integrated for the Google
G Suite user, and it's built in
Google Cloud Platform, as well.
So it has unlimited scalability,
it's built by former Googlers,
and it has all that security
and reliability that we've
heard all about this week.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Thank you, Craig.
And maybe for the
audience, there
will be multiple of
our recommended ISVs.
In fact, most of them are
actually built on GCP as well.
So if you have any questions
around scalability of GCP,
please feel free to ask those
questions later on, as well.
Radley, back to you.
You alluded to it to
some extent before,
but maybe on a higher level.
Can you speak to
how communications
have worked at Betts Recruiting,
and also how Dialpad actually
supports your anywhere workers?
RADLEY MEYERS: Absolutely, yes.
So communication
is pretty constant.
And once again, recruiting
most people we're recruiting
have jobs.
So we're not getting
callbacks during nine
to five business hours.
So a lot of those calls come at
6:00, 7:00, 8 o'clock at night,
and we were missing
those calls before.
So with the Dialpad
app, and knowing
that that number is the same,
it can link up to your phone,
it allows for communication,
for text messages,
for all of those things
to happen in real time
and not get bogged
down and slow down
our process of helping
people find a new job,
or fill headcount
on the client side.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
We stay with you.
Next question, telephony
touches everyone at a company.
And Betts Recruiting might be
a bit of a smaller company,
but still, everybody is very
concerned about telephony.
And we know usually that no
big IT transformation process--
and especially when it concerns
the telco infrastructure
as well--
goes without flaws.
Are there any learnings,
or what advice
would you give other IT
admins with regards to that?
And you see it probably a bit
more from the user perspective.
RADLEY MEYERS: Sure, yeah.
We're a young company,
we've only been around
about six or seven years.
But we've tried to
replace our telephony,
this is the third time.
And the first two times
were really rough.
So I had very low expectations
going into with Dialpad,
honestly.
And so the team there
was really great.
I think the biggest
piece of advice
that they helped me with was,
telephone is such an old,
like Craig was saying,
people are really used to it,
they're stuck in their ways.
They see a phone,
and that's the way
it should be and should
always be in their minds.
So getting people,
change management,
getting people bought in,
we worked really slowly.
We brought in some power
users, got them bought in.
Had them start to
train everybody else.
Our CEO, once she was
running around being
like, Dialpad is
awesome, this is great,
it kind of got people on board.
For us it was really
working slowly into it
and showing off all the great
features that I kind of talked
about earlier that helped
kind of avoid any issues,
or mitigate the issues
with any big IT change.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
I guess all of your
colleagues are probably
happy that you tried it for a
time, then, and made it work.
Thanks.
Craig, last question for you.
And I know you've been under
the pressure already of Cramer,
so you only have 30
seconds to answer this one.
What makes Dialpad unique,
and why should everybody
consider Dialpad?
What's the differentiators,
the big ones?
CRAIG WALKER: I'd say the
biggest differentiator is
we launched in
2015, so we didn't
have to build for
this past legacy
system of when people used
to spend nine to five sitting
at a desk.
We basically were able to
see how people were working
in the cloud, how
people were working
with their mobile devices,
how people were working,
and how we thought the
future of work would be.
So we were able to
build for that natively.
And we don't have any of
this legacy technical debt
of 10 years of
supporting desk phones
and trying to move them to
the cloud and bolt things on.
It's ultimately completely
built from scratch in the cloud,
for the cloud, entirely tailored
to be a seamless experience
with Google G Suite.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Thanks a lot.
Please, please
applaud, or join me
in applauding our
first Google panelists,
and we'll see them later on
again for the audience Q&A.
And I would love
to welcome on stage
our next group of
recommended ISVs, which
will be Virtru and Lumapps.
That's you.
JEB SEDER: Thank you, Thorsten,
for that brief introduction.
I'm Jeb Seder, I'm the
general manager for Lumapps,
and it's a great
pleasure to be here today
to introduce one of our favorite
and largest customers, which
is Veolia.
And I have Lucy Luo all the
way from France here with me
to join us today.
So thank you also to the
audience, the Friday afternoon
stalwarts, it's very impressive
to see all of you here.
Just two words about us.
We're a four-year-old
company, we're born in France,
and we are a corporate
and social portal
that offers enterprise
collaboration
and improves communication
with our employees.
Louder?
Thank you.
Were recommended by Google,
we're very proud of that,
to be part of their ISV family.
Just last Tuesday we won
a prize at the AT&T Park
for innovation, also
awarded by Google,
and we're thrilled with that.
And that's when you guys
with the yellow shirts
are supposed to stand
up and do the wave.
OK, thank you very much.
So Lumapps improves employee
interaction just like that.
And it's everything
you need to go to work.
So if you want to offer
employees, or collaborators,
or stakeholders, essentially
a boundless intranet, one that
is intuitive and
informed all at once,
we strongly suggest
you consider Lumapps.
So I'm very excited to be
here and introduce Lucy
as I mentioned.
We're very pleased with the
very thorough introduction
of Lumapps they've
done at their company,
which is an enormous
company that she's
going to tell you about.
So please join me in
welcoming Lucy Luo.
LUCY LUO: Thank you, Jeb, thank
you Thorsten for having me.
I'm very happy to be here.
Hello everybody, my name
is Lucy Luo from Veolia.
I'd like to start with a brief
introduction of the group
and its activities.
Veolia is the world
leader in water, energy,
and waste management services.
Today we have more
than 170,000 employees
in 50 countries worldwide.
As an example, here in
the United States Veolia
is present operating in 24
different cities such as New
York City and Los Angeles.
About three years ago,
Veolia took the first step
in the digital transformation
with G Suite, and within a year
80,000 employees were live.
So from then, we
started to transform
the way we work by introducing
innovative cloud applications.
At that time, Google
sites were already
being used to share
internal information.
So when we started thinking
about a new internet
with our HR department and
our communications department,
we had some key
challenges in mind.
First and foremost, we needed
to embody the One Veolia vision,
having everybody speaking
the same language.
You might ask, what
does that mean?
It means that news
need to be delivered
the same way across
50 different countries
that the group is operating.
Then we need to
provide our users
easy access to their
Google working environment.
They should be able to
find documents, business
applications, and content
that are relevant to them
in their own language.
And all this should
be made available
from a single entry point.
This single entry point that
we called the home site should
be capable of aggregating all
the information from Google
working place.
So you might have noticed
that we weren't just trying
to build a new
intranet, we're trying
to build a whole ecosystem of
internal websites and services.
After having considered
several options,
we have decided to
choose Lumapps, mainly
for its capacity of supporting
multi-language content,
for its native
integration with G Suites,
and its powerful search engine.
Jeb, maybe you want to talk
something about the video?
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
I think actually we
see a screenshot of how you
use it at Veolia, right?
That's an actual screenshot,
I believe, the rendering
that we have on the slide?
LUCY LUO: Yes, what you're
seeing here on your right hand
side is actually the home
page of our home site.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: I would
suggest in the interest of time
that we actually skip
the video for now,
and if somebody's interests they
would visit you at the booth
and see it there.
LUCY LUO: Sure.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
Because I think
it would be very
interesting for the audience
as well to see
just your-- so what
was the actual impact, then,
at Veolia after you implemented
it?
LUCY LUO: So our new intranet
that we call one to one
went live in May 2015.
So this is it, this is our
home site, the home page.
Our initial target
audience was 40,000 users
from nine different countries.
We reached that goal
in just three months.
Today in 2017, each of
our 90,000 active users
has by default
personalized information
based on their profile in
the Veolia group directory.
In addition to that,
they have the possibility
to customize the contents
in their own personal space
by bookmarking
favorite applications,
and by subscribing to news
feeds from other intranet sites.
Webmasters have the
possibility to choose
between Lumapps or Google
Sites depending on their needs.
From a communications
point of view,
users from different countries
can see top-down information
published by the headquarters,
and bottom-up information
sharing is made available
as well by the home site.
So thanks to the
success of this project,
we're now using Lumapps as
one of the standard solutions
for intranet sites.
And one to one has
certainly contributed
to making our group more
collaborative and more digital.
Thank you.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
Thank you, Lucy.
And I know Veolia and Lumapps
is such a great success story,
and is also at scale.
Because your rollout
is so large in terms
of licenses and employees using
Lumapps all across the world.
Jeb, I would be
curious, because I
know that your team,
and especially Elie,
the CTO of Lumapps, is always
coming up with new ideas
and builds new
integrations with G Suite.
There's some use
cases that I know
that you fulfill nowadays that
are actually not use by Veolia.
So what's new?
Is there anything that you
want to double click on?
JEB SEDER: I think
it might be worth
mentioning that effectively
the innovations continue
at Lumapps.
We're very proud of that.
And as some of you may know,
one of our main functions
that we offer is a social
network for corporate purposes.
That's something that Veolia
has not yet chosen to use,
they may do so in the future.
But other customers
have had a lot
of success with that
to improve, actually,
the direction that Lucy
was just describing.
That is, that it decreases
the isolation maybe
in a large organization, it
improves both horizontal,
vertical, and bottoms-up
communication,
and creates a
stronger community.
So that would be one thing.
And another would be Team
Drive was mentioned, I think,
by Thorsten earlier today.
It's obviously a great
improvement for the Google
Drive solution, and we have
adapted Lumapps in order
to work along with that, and
we're very pleased with that.
We, too, can help, in a
completely open system,
provide additional security in
terms of document management
so that the community remains
the owner of the document,
not the individual, which can
obviously be helpful over time.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Thank you Lucy, and thank you
Jeb for all those insights
throughout Veolia and Lumapps.
JEB SEDER: Thank you very much.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: We are
switching categories again
from one category that
touches almost everyone
in the organization corporate
portal to another topic,
and I mentioned it before,
security is one of the hottest
topics nowadays.
And I'm very pleased to
have Charles Gold here.
He's the CMO of
Virtru, our recommended
ISV in the encryption category.
Hi, Charles.
CHARLES GOLD: Thorsten, thank--
we all good?
All right.
Thank you, Thorsten.
So now I figured
out the microphone
I can introduce myself.
So my name is Charles Gold,
I'm the chief marketing officer
at Virtru.
We are a business privacy
and data security company.
So on top of G Suite,
we make it very easy
to add encryption, access
control, and DLP to G Suite
applications.
And with me today I'm
very pleased to be
joined by Bill Daugherty.
He's the VP of IT and
security at Omada Health.
And Omada Health is super cool.
They are literally saving lives,
but through corporate wellness
programs that are data driven.
But I won't do it justice,
I'll turn it over to Bill
to explain what
he's doing at Omada.
BILL DOUGHERTY:
Thank you very much.
Omada is a digital
health care company.
We are focused on obesity
related chronic diseases,
preventing them,
primarily type 2 diabetes.
It's estimated that over
80 million people are
at risk for that disease
just in this country,
and it is almost
100% preventable.
So we have a
digital program that
combines digital scales,
wearable technologies,
and online application
health coaches
to help people
relearn behaviors.
To eat better, exercise more,
lose weight, and ultimately
live a healthier life.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
And welcome, Bill.
BILL DOUGHERTY: Thank you.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
I would be curious,
and probably the audience
is as curious as I am,
why did you choose
to actually start
researching email encryption
providers for Omada Health,
and what use cases does
Virtru solve for you?
BILL DOUGHERTY: Sure.
So as a health care provider,
we're a regulated company,
and email is the bane of the
existence for most health care
providers, because
it's the easiest
way for protected
health information, PHI,
to leak out of your company.
We had a solution that
was a gateway product.
Meaning the e-mails were leaving
the company, would get scanned,
and if that solution thought
that it contained something
sensitive, it would encrypt it.
The trouble is that, that
operator's a black box.
Meaning we couldn't
customize the rules,
and the end user didn't
actually know if the email had
gone out encrypted or not.
The other big problem
we were trying to solve
is because it was
a gateway solution,
the email still stayed
unencrypted in the user's
sent mailbox.
And so we looked
at that and said,
it wasn't secure
enough as a method
for protecting our participants'
very private information.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Charles, maybe a follow
up question for you.
With regards to
your customers, I
know you have so many customers,
and lots of our largest G Suite
customers are also
your customers.
Why are they adding Virtru
to their G Suite domain?
CHARLES GOLD: Yes,
so privacy has
become an incredibly hot topic
in virtually every industry.
So we really see in our
thousands of customers
two primary drivers
at the highest level.
So it's either
regulation, so HIPAA,
or CJIS, or FERPA, or any
of these regulatory regimes,
or data residency that
you see around the world.
So that's probably
half of our customers
are choosing it for that reason.
The other half is what
I'd call business privacy.
So we've got media
companies who are choosing
us to protect source
information, entertainment
companies using us to protect
scripts, manufacturing
organizations using us
to protect manufacturing
plans and their supply chain.
So it's either business
privacy or regulation.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Bill, I think you alluded to
it to a certain extent before,
but I think what
would be interesting
is, what were the major benefits
that you've received out
of switching to Virtru from
the gateway solution before?
BILL DOUGHERTY:
Yeah, so Virtru's
a very cool product in that
it runs on the client side,
it runs on a browser hook, and
that offered certain benefits
to us.
First of all, it gave the user
control over whether or not
to encrypt a message or not.
And when they do
choose to encrypt it,
it gets persisted on
their side, and the
sent mail also encrypted.
But it's also a very
good educational tool.
In that you're able
to write rules for it
to flag what may be
sensitive information,
and if somebody hits
Send and forgets
to turn Virtru on, the browser
plugin will come up and say,
hey, I think your message
may be sensitive because
of these parameters.
And the default behavior
then is a button that says,
Send Secure.
So not only does it increase
the security overall of our mail
platform, but it helps
educate our end users
as to what actually constitutes
sensitive or private
information.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: And just
as a follow up for you,
so what are the features that
are most valuable from Virtru
for you?
BILL DOUGHERTY: Number
one is the rules engine,
being able to craft rules
specific to our data.
We know that our
reports are probably
80% of the possibility
for information
to leak out in an
unsecure manner.
And they follow a set pattern.
So I was able to tailor a rule
specific to what our data looks
like, and anytime a
report gets e-mailed,
if the person generating
it and sending it
didn't already
flag it, it's going
to get flagged and sent secure.
The other is the browser plugin
gives the end user the ability
to set things like
additional controls
like disable forwarding,
expiration dates.
And if they make a mistake,
they send it to somebody
and they didn't intend
to, they can instantly
revoke that message themselves.
They don't have to get an
administrator involved.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Thank you, Bill.
Charles, last question for you.
Because I see people from Virtru
mostly on the engineering prog
management side in our
building walking in and out
all the time.
Can you share some of the
things that you're currently
working on that we
might see from Virtru?
We've got so
integrations very soon.
CHARLES GOLD: Yeah, absolutely.
So one thing which is relatively
new, but is in the market today
is our customer key server.
So we see many
customers with a desire
to host their own
encryption keys
on their premises in a private
cloud, in a public cloud.
That really gives them exclusive
control of their content.
So that's one big thing
which is in market today.
Things that we're working
on include our integration
with Drive, which
is in beta, that
allows you to protect files
that you store in Drive,
and have those protections
persist regardless of where
those files are shared.
And then secondly, we're working
on encrypted storage under GCP.
So for organizations
that finally
want to migrate all of
those files and data
that they've been storing
on premise to the cloud,
but for regulatory or
business privacy reasons need
to encrypt it, we will soon
have a solution in that space.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Thank you, Charles,
and I thank all of you
for being on the second
group of the panel.
And we're rotating
again, and I would
like to invite AODocs
and RingCentral on stage.
So next to me we
have Stephan Donze.
Stephan is the founder
and CEO of AODocs,
and AODocs is one
of our recommended
ISVs in the document management
system space, as well.
Good to have you here, Stephan.
Who did you bring us today?
STEPHANE DONZE: So with
me is Rosemary Arce.
She's the lead IT collaboration
architect at Seagate.
So a few words about AODocs.
So AODocs has been
traded in 2012.
We're a document
management platform
built on top of Google.
Actually, we started
even before Google Drive
was officially released.
And with the vision
that we could combine
the ease of use of Google
and this capability in all
of the Googleness
of Google Drive
with the requirements
of enterprises
about control and processes
in document management.
So I think today AODocs is
kind of combining those two
worlds together to let
the enterprises apply
their compliance, their business
processes, their document
control, while enjoying
all of the ease of use
and the flexibility
of Google Drive.
And I think Rosemary would
give you a few examples on how
they do that at Seagate.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Welcome Rosemary, and
good to see you again.
Full disclosure for the
audience, Rosemary and I
have been in those type of
panel situations before.
And I can highly
recommend that whenever
you have a question with
regards to AODocs and G Suite,
please feel free to
reach out to Rosemary,
because she's extremely
knowledgeable.
ROSEMARY ARCE: You have a hard
time stopping me sometimes.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: I know.
We make it work today.
So I think everybody's
curious, what
was the baseline at Seagate?
Seagate everybody knows, I
believe, in this audience,
because it's a tech audience.
But what was the
baseline that made
you consider a new document
management system solution?
ROSEMARY ARCE: At the time,
we had been a Google Apps
customer.
We're an early adopter, so
we'd been on it for five years.
And we had made the
commitment to try to be
Cloud as much as we could.
But really, the impetus for
this was kind of interesting
now thinking about it, given
all the ways I use AODocs now.
Was that I had an aging
Lotus Notes repository
called Lotus Notes
Quicker, and you
have to really go back in time
to figure out what that was.
From your perspective,
it was thousands
of databases in a Lotus
Notes proprietary format
that was UI based.
It had about four
terabytes of data.
Of the thousands and thousands
of documents in there,
there were up to 200, to
300 versions per document,
And we wanted to move those.
We needed to get out,
because basically IBM was
going to pull the plug.
We kept it as long as we could.
And we needed to migrate
that with all of the features
intact.
So we weren't asking for much.
I wanted a migration.
I wanted all of the documents.
I wanted all of the versions,
along with the metadata
associated with each version.
And I wanted them
to be completely
in the same hierarchy
and permissions
as they were when they were
in the other interface.
And that's all I needed.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
That's all you needed.
ROSEMARY ARCE:
That's all I needed.
We're very pushy where we're at.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: And Stephan
and team made it happen,
or what were the
key features that--
ROSEMARY ARCE: So initially
we went out looking to see,
does anybody do that?
Does anyone migrate
what was at that point
an 8-year-old product, and
take it out of Lotus Notes,
and move it anywhere?
I didn't even care where it was.
USB stick, it would
have been fine.
And it became quickly apparent
that that wasn't an easy thing
to find.
And we discovered that AODocs
had a migration tool for Lotus
Notes, not specifically for
Quicker, so we talked to them.
And then we were pleasantly
surprised that not only
did they have a migration
tool, but their end state
for migration, Google
Drive was an option,
and using the Google
infrastructure was an option.
And they all supported
some of the features
that I didn't mention
which oh, by the way,
we need workflow
associated with this,
and we need to be able
to get all the components
and put Humpty Dumpty
back together again.
And we need check in,
check out capability
of all of these documents.
Which is why we had kind of
written off Google Drive,
because we knew it couldn't
do any of the above.
And so then we started
the inquisition of AODocs.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
And then could you
speak to what was the
impact at Seagate?
ROSEMARY ARCE: So we went with
the migration tool, the impact
first of all, was huge.
It did what we asked it to.
If you were to look at a
10-year-old Lotus Quicker--
and we had do it in place,
because some of them
were legally bound
to not lose the data.
If you were to look
at a single document,
look at the permissions and
see where it was located,
and who it had access to, you
would find the exact same thing
in AODocs.
You would find if you wanted
to know what Version 201 looked
like, and who
edited it, and what
data edited it, to this day you
would still see exactly that.
They provided the web UI that
the group was familiar with.
We actually didn't want them
to look like Google Drive,
even though they could
have with the product.
We said, no, we want the web UI.
It looks virtually identical.
We were able to create
templates that looked identical.
And for those databases
that had workflow,
the workflow is there.
It does, and in fact, can
do more than it could ever
do in Lotus Notes.
So that combined
with the metadata.
And you know, I want to
underscore the metadata.
In the Lotus Notes environment,
when you have a record,
there can be six files
associated with that record,
and there can be different
properties associated
with the file.
So it wasn't a Google
Drive equals one file,
and AODocs equals one file.
I wanted him to put
the record up there,
point it to the exact six
files that were associated,
and all of the fields that
were associated with that file.
And they did that
with very little--
I scheduled all kinds
of training sessions.
We're talking about 1500 users.
I was ready, I was going
to have to train them.
I ended up canceling
most of them.
I only had to do three
or four, I recorded them,
and people did
not ask questions,
they just kept working.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Very good, very good.
And I know how pleased
you are with AODocs.
Thank you, Rosemary.
Stephan, last question
for you, and maybe
a short bulleted form.
What are key
differentiators of AODocs,
and why should everybody
consider looking into AODocs
and visiting you at
your booth or later?
STEPHANE DONZE: Yeah, so the key
things, and I kind of touched
that in the beginning, is we are
combining all of the features
that Rosemary was talking about.
We are replacing
sharp point, replacing
all of those old systems
with the same feature level,
and sometimes even superior
feature levels, but in a way
that respects the Google
user experience that
makes it easy for the end user.
So the feedback we get
from all of our customers,
oh my god, this is so much
easier than [INAUDIBLE],
this is so much easier
than Lotus Notes,
it's so much easier than Open
Text, and so on and so forth.
We bring those systems to
the Google environment,
to the Google user
experience, and it gets them
to be so much more productive.
So it's really our
integration with the G Suite,
our embracement
of the simplicity,
the flexibility, the
collaboration aspects of the G
Suite.
And even more than that, we
have built an operating system.
So we think of AODocs not
just as a box in which you can
put documents, it's a platform.
So it's integrated with
G Suite, obviously,
but it's also integrated with
the rest of the ecosystem.
We work with Docusign, we can
have a document in AODocs,
send it to Docusign,
get it back signed.
We work with virtual, we can
have the virtual encryption
engine that was
described by Charles,
and apply to AODocs
content, and have
AODocs enforce the
encryption for you
so that you get the compliance
levels that you need to have.
And even getting further, all
of the new things that you've
seen in this conference
about GCP, the DLP features,
the image recognition
features, all of these,
we're bringing that into
AODocs to add even more value
to your documents.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
Thank you, Stephan.
I know there are so many
features that you have.
Could you please hand over--
STEPHANE DONZE: I could
continue for two hours.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
I know, I know.
And I would encourage
everyone to speak to Stephan.
He's also very knowledgeable
about the GCP world of ours.
But we're switching gears,
going back into the UCaaS space,
and I'm very happy that we
have the ABP of Alliances
from RingCentral, Eric
Bohren here with us today.
Hello, Eric.
ERIC BOHREN: Thanks, Thorsten.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: And who
did you bring with you today?
ERIC BOHREN: I
brought Mack Khorrami,
who heads up IT infrastructure
at the FOSSIL group.
Which is the watch company
and wearable company
you guys are all familiar with.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Welcome, Mack.
I don't think we need to
have a proper introduction
about FOSSIL, because everybody
knows the brand probably.
But with regards
to the baseline,
when did you consider
switching telco providers,
and actually looking into a
solution that's more like UCaaS
and more progressive
like RingCentral?
MACK KHORRAMI: So
we're a global company.
Our products are sold in more
than 100 countries globally.
We have 600 retail
stores globally,
with 300 in US and Canada,
and rest in EMEA and APAC.
A few years ago we started
working on our Omni channel.
To implement the
correct Omni channel,
you needed a very nice
steady, stable infrastructure.
To do that, at that time
our retailer stores had
only three POTS
lines with no IVR
capability, no good functions.
So we started looking,
we talked to Cisco,
we talked to Avaya back then,
but the price was really
out of our range.
What we did, we went
ahead and talked to AT&T,
and AT&T came to us
and said, hey, we
have this product that we
think you're going to like.
It's in your price range, and
one of the local retailers
in Dallas area uses it as well.
So that's how the
journey started.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
ERIC BOHREN: And Mack,
you adopted communications
in the cloud, which is
critical to the productivity
of your stores, in 2014.
So you're really
leading the curve
in terms of moving
communications with cloud.
What kind of
comfort did you give
to your key stakeholders
in FOSSIL group
that this was the
right move to make?
MACK KHORRAMI: So
I'm old Telco guy,
I used to work for a carrier.
So I knew how hard it is for
partners to get certified.
So one of the major selling
points to my customers
and to our customers was that
AT&T has certified RingCentral.
And another one, we discussed
it with the local retailer,
we discussed to see how
they're comfortable with it.
And I promised our
internal customers
that we will have a solid
plan, we will test everything
in our lab, and we
will not implement it
without they actually
see it for themselves.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
ERIC BOHREN: And
so Mack, what use
cases were critical to
your evaluation for FOSSIL?
MACK KHORRAMI: IVR
was number one.
Basically productivity
was very important to us.
We don't want our
retail employees
to waste their time on phone.
So if they were
assisting a customer,
and they would get a call,
the caller could actually
select the button,
and they would
talk to somebody like with
our Richardson office.
In addition, we enabled
eight digit dialing.
So in New York we have
five stores right next
to each other.
So if they wanted
to help a customer,
instead of calling the store
by the old MPA and execs,
they could just use the
stored number and call them.
So that was very nice.
And also they could
call corporate,
and corporate can call eight
digit dialing by just the store
numbers.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE: Excellent.
Thank you.
Eric, I would have
a question for you.
I know that you have
so many features
within the entire
RingCentral product suite,
and like integration points that
we have with G Suite with you,
and FOSSIL might not
be using all of them.
Are there any special
features that you
would like to talk to the
audience about that FOSSIL
might not use?
ERIC BOHREN: Yeah.
Just to give you
a flavor, I mean,
we're the largest peer
play communication
provider in our space.
And so that allows us
to invest tremendously.
We invest about
$60 million a year
in all the enterprise
applications
that you might want.
So for sales, you could use
Salesforce or ProsperWorks
to automatically log the
activity of all your calls
into the system of record.
Thereby kind of removing
manual processes,
making it more productive,
and reducing human error.
And then if you move on
to service management,
it could be
ServiceNow or Zendesk,
where general productivity, both
customers and partners of ours
are Box, and Octa, and
we work in conjunction
to create these unified
experiences that effectively
create digital processes
that were previously manual.
So that's one of the
big, we basically
can cater to all
these use cases.
In fact, I was thinking
about the previous panel
up here, we have
specialty providers even
in recruiting that do bulk
SMS to recruits to push them
through the funnel for
recruiting purposes, as well.
THORSTEN LUEDECKE:
Excellent, excellent.